this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling
biomutan's post-apocalyptic open world
differs from the norm
even if it's guilty of adhering to a few
familiar tropes
the remnants of its neglected towns are
still populated by dilapidated buildings
and roaming bandits
and its overgrown roadways are littered
with the burnt out husks of abandoned
vehicles
but biomutant also utilizes a vivid
color palette that makes its verdant
feels and picturesque red mountains pop
with the kind of striking vibrancy
that's rarely associated with the
apocalypse
throw in some furry anthropomorphic
creatures and biomutants character
design and general style is certainly
atypical of the genre
yet it also consists of a mishmash of
fairly obvious influences
from a breath of the wild esque
structure to combo driven combat that's
similar to devil may cry
and other familiar elements from the
likes of fallout max payne
and borderlands it's a flavorful petri
dish for sure
but there are plenty of uneven and drab
aspects to its overall design and
structure
the mixture between old and new ideas
doesn't always sit right
but biomutant also manages to carve out
its own identity
amid its many inspirations
this begins with a character creator as
you step into the flusculent skin of one
of the aforementioned creatures
an odd hybrid between a squirrel rat and
any other scurrying critter that comes
to mind
choosing a breed affects your starting
stats to a certain degree and you can
pump points into specific attributes if
you fancy
say dealing more melee damage or
increasing your chances of bartering
with merchants
it's your typical by the numbers rpg
progression system
there's some personality to the
character creator as your body shape
will change
depending on which stats you opt to
emphasize big head for intellect
big biceps for strength for example
ultimately however your starting
attributes aren't especially significant
you're able to put 10 points into a
category each time you level up
so it's easy to build a fairly
well-rounded character within a few
hours
the final part of creating your
character involves picking a class which
impacts both your starting weapon
and the addition of a unique skill the
commando for instance
inflicts 10 percent more damage with
ranged weapons while the scythe reek
gets access to a lightning attack that
otherwise isn't available to the other
classes
these aren't game changing skills and
you'll be swapping out weapons by the
dozen in no time at all but they do add
a smidgen of variety to subsequent
playthroughs
the latter example is also one of the
few instances where biomutant will lock
you out of using a specific ability
in other cases even if you pick a class
such as a rogue-like saboteur you're
still able to use psi powers and
biogenetics
and wield any of the available weapon
types so there's plenty of freedom to
play the game how you want
the only other time you're unable to
lock certain abilities when you come
across side powers are dependent upon
your aura alliance
biomutant's aura system is split into
light and dark sides
with good and bad deeds affecting your
standing in each
it's a typical morality system with your
deeds and dialogue choices
impacting how others see you you're not
locked into either light or darkness
once you start going down one path
so there is some flexibility to play as
a morally grey character and dabble in
both sides of the spectrum
in truth the majority of your choices
have insignificant impact on biomutant
story
the biggest decision you'll make occurs
within the game's first hours as you're
asked to align with one of two tribes
while the obvious light-sided tribe
wants you to unite other clans and
defeat the four deadly weldies to save
the world
the darksider tribe would prefer you did
the opposite by conquering the other
clans and defeating the world ears to
cleanse the world and start anew this
essentially sets up your overarching
objective and impacts the ending you'll
get if you decide to stick to your
chosen path
but doesn't change the missions you'll
embark on to get there beating the
worldias and capturing the other tribe
outpulse makes up the bulk of the game
either way
and the narrative just isn't interesting
enough to make your choices feel
meaningful
the story contextualizes your progress
and gives you a reason to push on
but there's little else to it the
presence of an amiable narrator is a
nice touch
and this omniscient voice does add a
dash of personality to the game
it's a bridge just get over it
the narrator also acts as a translator
for every character in the game
which doesn't mean characters struggle
to stand out since they all share the
same voice
best be careful you're a key figure now
the writing doesn't do the cost any
favors in this regard either
with most characters existing to spew
exposition and law before sending you on
a fetch quest
it's clear that a lot of effort was put
into fleshing out the backstory of this
post-apocalyptic world
or at least throwing in as many kooky
names as possible
but being told about it by a verbal
salvo that foregoes any sense of
character isn't an engaging way to
absorb it
particularly when adopting the tell
don't show approach
unimaginative mission design compounds
the story's shortcomings
as your quest to defeat all four worldly
is always boils down to a formulaic back
and forth
the general structure is decent enough
with the trio of life
looming high in the center of the map
its mammoth roots dying out into four
different directions
there's a worldly awaiting at the end of
each route and a supporting character
that's willing to help you reach them
the problem is that the way you reach
each one is always the same
you meet a character they reveal the
vehicle you need to use then you're sent
to grab a part they need to get it
working and repeat
the vehicles themselves offer a nice
change of pace with a hulking mech
and gun-toting speed boat on the agenda
among others but the journey is always
short
and quick making the worldias feel
anti-climactic
it's also a tad odd that you spend the
game building up your own character only
to defeat the game's biggest files while
behind the wheel of various vehicles
combat is fun in short bursts too
although it takes a couple of hours to
find its footing both the dodge and the
parry mechanics require some time to get
the hang of
the automatic lock-on is inconsistent
and your starting moves and weapons are
underwhelming
once your arsenal opens up and you
attain a few more combos the combat
begins to find its groove
albeit one that is dictated by routine
you're always equipped with both melee
and ranged weapons and each weapon type
has its own simple combos
if you perform three different combos in
the middle of a fight you can enter a
state of super wong
food where you're able to pummel enemies
with a rapid barrage of attacks
soar through the air in bullet time to
rain down shots or deliver a devastating
ground pound to disperse crowds
combat is built around reaching super
wonkful so most fights consist of the
same three combo
routine this isn't necessarily a bad
thing but your repertoire of combos
isn't particularly expensive
psi powers and their mutated biogenetics
add more variety to the combat
allowing you to blaze a trail of fire or
encase yourself within a mucous bubble
that enemies will be helplessly sticking
to
judicious use of slow motion also gives
your attacks a sense of tangible impact
and the relatively infrequent nature of
combat works in its favor when it comes
to staving off repetition
in between fights you're incentivized to
explore biomutants open world with the
promise of loot
old brick racks like that sometimes
still
full of good things each location even
features a convenient checklist so you
know if you're missing anything
although you occasionally find new
weapons and armor when scavenging
through the wreckage of derelict
buildings
loot is more geared towards attaining
better materials since the best weapons
in the games are ones that you make
yourself
biomutant's crafting system is dynamic
with an almost limitless amount of
concoctions available
for you to build the items you make are
essentially repurposed garbage
as use whatever rusty contraptions you
can get your hands on whether it's an
oversized toothbrush that was previously
attached to a billboard
or the handle of a broken vacuum cleaner
experimenting with different
combinations that shouldn't work is part
of the crafting system's charm
and provides you with a sense of
ownership over your nonsensical
inventions
as long as it does the job having said
that both melee and ranged weapons are
split into distinct categories such as
one-handed slash
automatic rifles and so on the weapons
within these categories don't feel all
that different from one another
which does take some of the shine off
the crafting system
charging into battle with a new weapon
that has an enhanced damage number is
still inherently satisfying though
biomutant often has these moments where
systems don't quite cooperate and you
end up with something uneven
while combat is fun in moderation and
the crafting system is bizarre in all
the right ways
the flip side of this is dull and
monotonous quest design
unforgettable story and hollow morality
there's still an enjoyable game here
but a lot of unfortunate caveats come
attached to that statement
while it might not always hit the mark
biomutant is an ambitious but flawed
game from a small studio
and the games industry could always use
more risky endeavors like this one
[Music]
you